I was getting a broadcast degree and I
recall coming back from an assignment JD
would appreciate this nice Italian
professor of mine very nice when you
when you have a name like carmine you
get along with Italian professors really
well but JB I came back and I didn't
have a story because there was no story
at least that's what I told the prof and
he yelled at me and he just got into me
and grilled me there's always a story
gallo there's always a story that advice
serve me really well in my career as a
journalist at CNN as my in my books and
my writing and certainly in my career
today as a communications consultant
there's always a story so all of you
have a story to tell some of you are
better than others at telling your story
but you all have the ability to tell a
better story to share your ideas to
inspire people with those stories and so
I think as future business leaders you
need to think about how am I going to
inspire people how do I inspire my team
how do I inspire investors to back my
products how do I inspire people to
really rally around my ideas and my
initiatives how do you do that I believe
that there are three components the
inspiration an inspiring message has to
be understandable memorable and
emotional you have to have all three
once all three elements take place
that's where inspiration occurs you need
to reach someone's head and their heart
now how do you do that how do you do
that through a business pitch how do you
do that in a simple PowerPoint
presentation or a conversation with a
professor or an investor how do you
truly inspire people what I'd like to do
today is spend the next 30 minutes or so
revealing some very specific techniques
that you can use today right after this
workshop to inspire
your classmates your professors your
stakeholders your team members anybody
in which you need to persuade them to
take some sort of action so today is all
about inspiration presentation skills
communication that's how we get there
but it's all about inspiration how do
you inspire the people in your life
because that's the definition of
leadership true leaders inspire people
to a bigger vision how do you do that
that's what we'll talk about today
before I reveal the techniques that I
think all of you can apply I do need to
talk about the foundation of all great
communications the one technique per se
that I can't teach you could listen to
the rest of this workshop you can listen
to all of the methods that I'm going to
teach you and really apply them but if
you don't have passion for your topic
it's not going to make any difference
passion is everything you cannot inspire
unless you're inspired yourself brest
mentioned I wrote the presentation
secrets of Steve Jobs one of the most
astonishing things about Steve Jobs as a
great corporate communicator was that he
wasn't necessarily passionate about
computers he was passionate about
creating tools to help you unleash your
personal creativity he was passionate
about building tools that would change
the world and he wore that passion on
his sleeve passion is contagious I
learned a lot about passion from this
man Howard Schultz I learned a lot about
passion and communications
I interviewed Howard Schultz for a book
I wrote several years ago and I recall
having about an hour conversation with
him and rarely did he mention the word
coffee because he wasn't selling coffee
he was selling a workplace that treats
people with dignity and respect he was
selling customer service he was selling
employee engagement that's what he was
passionate about it wasn't about the
coffee watch this clip from CNBC listen
to how a great communicator and a
successful leader like Howard Schultz
communicates
vision behind his brand and also watch
for the reaction of the TV host because
he had the exact same reaction I did
when I interviewed Howard Schultz
Starbucks innocence has become the
quintessential experience brand and the
experience comes to life by our people
we've been able to I think create a
system of attracting retaining great
people building a training system that
replicates what we do and I think the
only competitive advantage and this is
you know an anastomotic and to a tech
companies we have no patent we have no
secret sauce whatsoever the only
competitive advantage we have is a
relationship we've built with our people
in a relationship they have built with
the customer so when we go to you let
your competitive advantage you haven't
worked mentioned word coffee not your
competitive advantage is not your cause
well I'll get to the quickest said you
can get energy I agree with the
relationship yeah with your people and
the people with therapy with the best
and in fact if you ask me what business
we're in we're in the people business
we're not in the coffee business
of course we are as a product but we're
in the people business 135,000 people
hiring three hundred people a day
serving forty million customers a week
it's all human connection it's a sense
of humanity in the sense of community
that we've built in our stores so at the
end of the day what we've been able to
do is crack the code on being able to
create an environment where people are
treated well they're respected they're
valued customers come in and they
recognize this is a different kind of
environment almost an oasis almost an
oasis what is he talking about what is
he really selling you need to ask
yourself what is it that I'm passionate
about and you need to dig deep to find
that I love it at the end of one of
Steve Jobs as great presentations one of
his last presentations he said it's the
intersection of Technology and liberal
arts that makes our hearts sing and so
now I ask clients that question
I don't even ask them what are you
passionate about now it's what makes
your heart sing the answer to that
question is a lot different than the
answer to what do you make what do you
do how is it different
that's a much more inspiring answer so
you need to dig deep and identify what
am i passionate about and what really
makes my heart sing and don't be afraid
to express your emotion about it passion
is contagious I'm not going to go into
the studies but there are now numerous
studies which show people who are
passionate and enthusiastic and excited
guess what it does rub off on people
be passionate that's number one but now
let me reveal several techniques that
you can use today to make your everyday
messages your messages your powerpoints
or pitches a little more inspiring so
let's talk about the role that you're
going to play as a communicator and as a
leader I'm going to break this up into
three acts Act one how do we make it
understandable how do we make our
message clear easy to get understandable
there are a number of techniques we
could talk about it all day but there's
one in particular I do want to mention I
did talk about this two years ago when I
talked to the graduate students here at
Stanford it's as relevant today as it
was two years ago
creating Twitter friendly headlines I
love Twitter as an exercise Twitter how
many of you are on Twitter right now
okay okay
many more of you every time I ask that
question of students like every year
more and more and more my twitter handle
is just my name if you'd like to follow
me it's carmine gallo so go ahead and
follow me I'd love to have a
conversation with you on Twitter okay so
how many characters is to it does
Twitter allow you know 140 not very much
one sentence if you can't describe what
you do in one sentence of 140 characters
do me a favor go back to the drawing
board let's try again you need to give
people the big picture the brain craves
meaning before a detail this is one of
those big revelations I learned in
communications theory and I learned it
from John Medina at the University of
Washington who said carmine when
primitive man ran into a tiger he did
not ask how many teeth does the tiger
have
pS will it eat me should I run big
picture before details big picture what
do you do in 140 characters or less
when Wendy Kopp started Teach for
America in 1989 she told me that she had
a one-sentence vision to reduce
educational inequities and that was the
vision statement that she presented to
investors and stakeholders it served her
very well more than 20 years later
that's still the vision to reduce
educational inequities today more than
30,000 students have gone through a
program teaching underprivileged kids
around the country now some of you would
know better than I but I believe unless
I'm wrong I believe that Teach for
America is the number one College
recruiter is it not one of the top
college recruiters yeah I mean very
successful but again how do you describe
something to investors she had to go out
and get investors this was a Princeton
project okay was it was a dissertation
she had to go out and get investors
excited about her idea but they needed
to see the big picture first what was
she trying to accomplish here in the Bay
Area when Sergey Brin and Larry Page
walked into Sequoia Capital they had one
sentence one sentence and the investor
said they got it immediately Google
provides access to the world's
information in one click an investor
from Sequoia Capital told me that in one
sentence we got it big picture before
details and that was about ten words
before Twitter an investor told me that
he wants a 10 word summary of what you
do if he said if you can't describe what
you do in 10 words I'm not interested in
investing that was before Twitter now I
think it's more relevant to keep it to
about 140 characters you should probably
get to know this guy he's changed all of
your lives his name is Ellie Harare
that's me and Ellie when we were in a
conference room working on some
messaging Ellie Harare is the pioneer of
flash he created flash
memory so the memory that enables all of
your iPads to work your mp3s to work now
and you're in your laptops you guys use
digital cameras all of you have him to
thank for those digital cameras because
he invented the flash memory cards that
go inside those digital cameras I bring
this up because people at the highest
levels of corporate business today
people who are worth hundreds of
millions of dollars billions of dollars
are constantly thinking about how do I
communicate the vision behind my company
more effectively getting back to Twitter
friendly headlines this is was a
workshop we were working on it
he had to give a huge conference in
front of all the analysts it's called
analyst days so every year
public companies give one day where they
talk to all the analysts and we were
going around the room and I asked
everyone for a Twitter friendly headline
and of course some of the engineers were
pushing back you know they said now
we've got way too much way too much
information
we can't just distill it into into a 140
characters and Ellie said no wait a
minute wait a minute the analyst in the
room that day don't realize that flash
will be bigger than they think this was
2009 before the iPad came out now
flashes in the iPad he was absolutely
right the stock has gone straight up so
over the last few years
Ellie was right but the analysts in the
room didn't quite appreciate that at the
time so that was his Twitter friendly
headline in the coming decade flash will
be bigger than you think guess what
happened within three hours as the rest
of the analyst conference was going on
there were actually analysts tweeting
they were tweeting this flash will be
bigger than you think what was the
headline on a lot of the blog's flash
will be bigger than you think what did
we do we controlled the message we
reframed the message but you hat you
can't control the message if it's
confusing and convoluted so how do you
make it clear how do you make it
understandable big picture before
details Apple and Steve Jobs they do
this all the time
and I still like to talk about Apple
because I believe that as far as the
corporations are concerned they get
communications they understand creating
compelling messages what was the iPod in
2001 it was an ultra portable mp3 music
player that put a thousand songs in your
pocket in one sentence I got it
immediately 2007 Apple reinvented the
phone in 2008 Apple introduced MacBook
Air in a sentence the world's thinnest
notebook the world's thinnest notebook
what a great headline it was consistent
on all of their press releases on the
in-store signage Steve Jobs said this
during a presentation that's all you
need to know it's the world's thinnest
notebook if you want to learn more go to
the website but in one sentence you get
it immediately
every time you you introduce an
initiative an idea a product what's the
one sentence description for it what's
the big picture before the details last
year for Forbes I had this really fun
opportunity to interview Richard Branson
and we talked about communications and
he said carmine when I get pitched and
you know I I guess I didn't fully
appreciate that virgin group is made up
of like 300 companies he gets pitched
all the time he said when someone
pitches me it better be clear and
concise and easy to grasp and then he
gave me the sentence that became the
headline for my article he said carmine
if it can't fit on the back of an
envelope it's rubbish if your message
can't fit on the back of an envelope
it's rubbish so don't be rubbish create
that headline ask yourself how do I
explain my idea in 140 characters or
less takes a lot of discipline to do
that a lot of discipline but think about
how would my audience actually tweet it
so that's one method to make your
message understandable after that though
you need to flesh it out don't you you
need to sell the benefit you need to
actually be specific and tell me why
should I care now this is another
question that I learn to answer in
journalism school the one question that
your audience is going to have why
should I care
how is it going to improve my life Steve
Jobs was brilliant at this and that's
what initially gave me the idea to start
writing about Steve Jobs nobody did it
better than Steve Jobs and the beauty is
that a lot of his presentations are
still on YouTube so we can learn from
him to this day
2007 introduces the iPhone in two
minutes in two minutes he reveals the
problem that most people had a problem
that people didn't even realize they had
that was the genius of Steve Jobs that
was his vision he actually could
convince you that you had a problem you
didn't even know you had not a lot of
people can do that that's why he's hard
to replace but it watched this clip in
two minutes
he introduces a problem then offers a
solution and it makes some very specific
benefits behind that solution so here's
why you should care about a new phone
from Apple now why do we need a
revolutionary user interface I mean
here's four smartphones right Motorola Q
the BlackBerry palm treo nokia e62 the
usual suspects and what's wrong with
their user interface as well the problem
with them is really sort of in the
bottom 40 there it's it's this stuff
right here they all have these keyboards
that are there whether you need them or
not to be there and they all have these
control buttons that are fixed in
plastic and are the same for every
application well every application wants
a slightly different user interface a
slightly optimized set of buttons just
for it and what happens if you think of
a great idea six months from now you
can't run around and add a button to
these things they're already shipped so
what do you do it doesn't work because
the buttons and the controls can't
change they can't change for each
application and they can't change down
the road if you think of another great
idea you want to add to this product
well how do you solve this hmm
it turns out we have solved it we solved
it in computers 20 years ago we solved
it with a bitmap screen that could
display anything we want
put any user interface up and a pointing
device we solved it with the mouse right
we solve this problem so how are we
going to take this to a mobile device
but what we're going to do is get rid of
all these buttons and just make a giant
screen a giant screen now how are we
going to communicate this we don't want
to carry around a mouse right so what
are we going to do
Oh a stylus right we're going to use a
stylus No
who wants a stylus you have to get them
and put them away and you'll lose them
yuck nobody wants a stylus so let's not
use a stylus we're going to use the best
pointing device in the world we're going
to use a pointing device that we're all
born with were born with ten of them
we'll use our fingers we're going to
touch us with our fingers and we have
invented a new technology called
multi-touch which is phenomenal it works
like magic you don't need a stylus it's
far more accurate than any touch display
that's ever been shipped it ignores
unintended touches it's super smart you
can do multi-finger gestures on it and
boy have we patented it hey you know I'm
glad everybody's laughing because he
makes it funny
when's the last time you actually had
fun delivering a PowerPoint yeah he uses
Apple Keynote but you get the idea
when's the last time you actually had
fun delivering a presentation not too
often you see what I mean my passion
enthusiasm comes across but this is hard
to do that simplicity of communication
is very difficult to do everything I'm
talking to you about today you can't
just turn this in a few minutes you
really have to think through what's my
story how do I make it understandable
what's my Twitter friendly headline
Twitter friendly headlines sometimes can
take hours to develop I've worked with a
group of executives over some very very
complex technology and information you
can do it no matter how complex your
idea is you can actually create a one
sentence description for it but that
could
take ours then you have to ask yourself
why should my audience care why should
they care so these two things will help
you make your presentation and your
conversation more understandable which
is the first element of inspiration how
do I get it you get your audience to
start nodding in agreement okay I see
the category in which is placing this
new product I understand the benefits I
understand it
tell me more help me remember it stamp
it on my memory how are we going to do
that there's a number of techniques that
I could talk about well because you're
MBA students you deal a lot with finance
and data and analysis and numbers bring
numbers to life this is one excellent
method that you can use today bring
numbers to life put every statistic that
you deliver into a context that is
relevant to the audience so in 2001 when
Apple introduced the iPod for the first
time they said it contained 5 gigabytes
of storage 5 gigs means nothing to
anybody it's just a big number well not
today
but back then it was a big number 5 gigs
no 5 gigs is the equivalent of 1,000
songs oh I know that's more interesting
ok 1000 songs now I get it
1000 songs in your pocket which was the
brilliance of Steve Jobs Steve Jobs
would always take it one step further
most people would just deliver 5 gigs
smart communicators would say that's the
equivalent of 1,000 songs genius
communicators go one step above that
Apple continues to do this to this day
which is why Apple is so brilliant at
communicating information and messages
behind their products there's a whole
team of people back there and they work
really long and hard to communicate
interesting and engaging messages so
last year when Phil Schiller introduced
the new iPad Mini
I forgot how thin it was I'm going to
show you a clip and will it'll remind me
it was thin it was some kind of number
really thin I don't remember the number
I remember it was thin as a pencil I do
remember it was as light as a pad of
paper
sir what's more memorable to you the
data or what the data actually show
and the metaphor and the analogy that
the data create this takes work but
listen and watch how it turns out so
this iPad Mini is just seven point two
millimeters thin that's about a quarter
thinner than the fourth-generation iPad
to put it in context it's as thin as a
pencil that's that it weighs just point
six eight pounds that's over 50% lighter
than the previous iPad fourth-generation
so in context what can you compare that
to it's as light as a pad of paper we
were going to say a book but books are
much heavier so we came out with a pad
of paper you tell me isn't that far more
interesting than just introducing a
number that's memorable
that's the iconic photograph from that
particular presentation as well so ask
yourself what numbers can I bring to
life now we're going to focus on one
other technique that I think is one of
the most powerful techniques and
communications to make your message
truly memorable and easy for your
audience to grasp that's the rule of
three the rule of three simply means
that in short-term memory work in memory
I'm only going to be able to carry about
three or four points of information
so why overwhelm me with twelve don't
give me twelve or fifteen reasons why I
should back your idea give me three much
easier to grasp a I wrote about this for
Forbes and one of my readers actually
sent me an infographic his name is
Philippe Paco he created this
infographic it's on the rule of three I
know it's hard to read but it just shows
you how the rule of three pervades all
aspects of our society even religion
Father Son and the Holy Spirit slogans
Nike just do it Obama yes we can the
colors of the flags I hadn't realized
most flags have
recolors language science certainly
literature Three Little Pigs Three
Musketeers I'm a big fan of Thomas
Jefferson's writing life liberty pursuit
of happiness I had forgotten how many
companies have three letters in their
logo ups as ap IBM CNN the rule of three
okay that it's only because this is the
way our mind works naturally it likes to
see groups of three so use it in your
next presentation or pitch Apple does
this all the time all the time when iPad
2 was released I'll never forget I got
an email the subject line was iPad 2
thinner lighter faster that's a thinner
lighter faster that's all you need to
know about it in fact this pervades
design at Apple as well because again
design is simple at Apple not the
process to get there but the end result
there's only three models of iPads you
can choose from there's different
configurations but they introduced three
models three models of the iPhone
everything is in three three is very
powerful so now I'm going to show you
how to incorporate the rule of three
Twitter friendly headlines and selling
the benefit into what I call a message
map a message map is something that you
can use today for your very next pitch
no matter how complex your idea this is
going to help you a lot by creating a
message map you create a visual display
of information the visual display of
your story on one page this works
remarkably well because I've used it for
some a lot of products products that
actually you use in your everyday life
started we sold it with a message map
message map is not necessarily meant for
consumers it's meant for you to help you
articulate and visualize what the story
is behind your particular product
initiative or idea would you like me to
show you how to create a message map
okay let's do that
I'm going to make it
I could make this complicated I'm going
to make it very simple though I'm going
to go to the other extreme I'm going to
show you that you can make this for
anything even soap how many of you have
been to a store called lush it's a soap
store
okay good good number of you there's a
few here in the Bay Area there's a two
in San Francisco
it's a uk-based soap store and it has
about 150 locations in the US and Canada
it's very nice nice soap store but
what's the story behind it I have one of
the lush soaps here this particular bar
is $11.34 it's 37 dollars a pound
that's an expensive soap 37 bucks a
pound
so how many of you would pay more than
$10 for this small bar of soap oh come
on
not one oh you because you've been to
lush yeah
well you don't count but that's okay cuz
you already know what how good this is
so you don't know most of you don't know
the story behind it it's it's packaged
in a nice white paper does that convince
you no not at all smell here go ahead
and smell this does it smell good it's
mostly yeah very nice it's called Karma
see you again it'll give you a good
karma $38 a pound you interested still
not interested okay I'll give it to the
lady who wanted it to begin with you go
ahead um okay this because we don't know
the story behind it I do have another
bar let's go
let's create a message map so yes and I
have absolutely no connection to this
store whatsoever but I do
I like their soap now okay I'll let's
create a message map you need a sheet of
paper you need an iPad you need a
PowerPoint slide just anything that's
empty this is all you need to create or
a whiteboard I love to whiteboard so
that's all you need to create a message
map you start with a Twitter friendly
headline what's the one
you want people to know about your
product the one thing the most important
consistent thing based on my
understanding of the lush brand I did
interview the CEO last year I wrote a
story about them that's where my
connection ends but I know their
messaging really well here's what I
think their Twitter friendly headline is
lush crafts handmade soaps and cosmetics
handmade that's their key phrase their
key word it's on the the paper bags that
you take home the in-store signage the
advertising the marketing the website
handmade soaps and cosmetics so in one
sentence it helps you categorize it
Carolyn earlier said it's fancy soap so
okay fancy so maybe that could be a
headline too but this whole handmade
fancy soap allows me to categorize it
into another category now I know it's
probably a little different than the
soap that I would get at the grocery
store but I need more evidence give me
three reasons why I should consider lush
soap okay why don't we start with fresh
and organic everything all of the
ingredients here are fresh natural
they're made one day ship the next
everything is a non-toxic ingredient so
it's very very good for your skin it's
fresh and organic it's environmentally
friendly that's why it's not wrapped in
plastic that's why it's recyclable paper
so that there's no plastic that fills
the goes into landfills nothing that's
none of the ingredients or chemicals are
tested on animals so everything is
environmentally friendly and part of the
proceeds go to support ethical campaigns
campaigns in the community and also
campaigns on a global scale
there's your message map so you can see
how this works I can hand this message
map to a brand new employee who has only
been there for a couple of days somebody
walks into lush looks around says oh
this is interesting tell me more about
this store well at lush we craft
handmade soaps and cosmetics everything
you see here
in the store is fresh and it's natural I
with real natural ingredients that are
good for your skin
everything is environmentally friendly
that's why you'll find everything
wrapped in recyclable papers so we don't
fill landfills with trash and plastic
and part of the benefits go to support
some really cool ethical campaigns that
help people here in our own community
I'd love to tell you about but listen
why don't you go around and look around
I think you'll like what you see all of
a sudden becomes oh that's interesting
there's a real story behind it some of
their ethical campaigns I don't
necessarily agree with I fall on the
other side of some of their campaigns
just you know from a philosophical
perspective but guess what it's
interesting there's a story there's a
real story behind it and there's engaged
people as well that's a message Matt
it's very very simple to create since
you you know you get you can have that
one since you like the smell yeah now
you'll be giving off good karma do so
that's a message map but it doesn't work
without the rule of three you see how
you got to have all of the other things
we just talked about if you don't
understand the big picture you don't
understand the rule of three and selling
the benefit then nothing else matters
but you can't create a message map
without all of those other components
okay this works really really well I
have created a message map for big
companies very complex information and a
few weeks later the executives come back
to me and they say we just want a few
you know a multi-million dollar account
I don't take full credit but if they
want to credit a message map terrific
the reason why they credit the message
map is because for the first time they
have clarity in their message and if
they're clear on it it's clear to the
audience as well you can't confuse
people and finally we have to make our
messages emotional emotion is very
important chip Heath here at Stanford
John hi to the University of Virginia
they've all been using this metaphor
which is brilliant
most of you probably heard about it the
writer and the elephant
if you think about the way the brain
processes information the left brain
wants the data the analysis logic that's
the writer the person steering the
elephant the right brain more the
emotional part of the brain it's the
elephant the writer thinks he's in
control left brain thinks it's in
control but where the writer wants to go
that's where inspiration ultimately
occurs John Medina the University of
Washington made it even simpler for me
he said carmine the brain does not pay
attention to boring things he said the
brain is not programmed to grasp
abstract concepts okay so how do we get
past that how do we make a presentation
emotional tell stories no but nobody in
corporate America tells stories anymore
stories are undervalued they're under
appreciated they're underutilized tell
stories Marissa Meyer the new CEO of
Yahoo former VP of Google guess what she
doesn't presentations she tells stories
and she's considered very charismatic
somebody I know at a very large company
saw an internal presentation given by
Marissa Meyer and he came up to me a few
weeks later and he said carmine it was
amazing she spoke like 45 minutes and
she only used ten slides I asked him how
did she do that
well let's see oh she told stories no
kidding stories tell stories you could
tell stories about your product how it
came to be you could tell personal
stories you can tell stories about
customers a case study is a story and
when you were going to get to this in a
minute when you tell stories like
Marissa Mayer when she tells stories she
uses visual slides to complement her
stories the slides are not the story the
slide simply complement the story
stories are powerful I spoke to this
gentleman last year his name is Bryan
Stevenson Bryan Stevenson gave a TED
lecture at the end of that lecture he
inspired the audience to donate 1
million dollars to his nonprofit
the equal justice initiative he is
passionate about social justice he
argues cases before the US Supreme Court
and he won a landmark case last year it
is now unconstitutional to impose a
mandatory life sentence on a juvenile on
someone convicted as a juvenile
thanks to mr. Stevenson we had a
conversation about communications guess
what he said carmine I don't know what
to tell you you you say I'm charismatic
that's great I'm flattered I don't know
I just get up there and tell stories no
kidding that's why you're making an
emotional connection with people you
tell stories in this lecture I'm going
to show you a clip he started with a
story about his grandmother he tied it
into the theme the power of identity he
says a lot of poor underprivileged kids
and a lot of communities across America
don't have identity so how do you
connect that with your audience
let me tell a story about it so he tells
the story of his grandmother who when he
was 11 years old I believe pulled him
aside and said Brian I think you're
special and then she asked him to make a
promise the promise was never to drink
alcohol he said hey I was 11 years old I
didn't have anything to lose sure why
not I'll never drink alcohol grandma
here's how he picks up the story I grew
up in the country in the rural South and
have a brother you're older than me and
a sister you're younger when I was about
14 or 15 one day my brother came home
and he had this six-pack of beer I don't
know where he got it and he grabbed me
and my sister we went out in the woods
and we were kind of just out there doing
the stuff we crazily did and he had a
sip of this beer and he gave some to my
sister and she had some and they offered
it to me I said no no no no that's okay
y'all go ahead I'm not going to have any
beer my brother said come on we're doing
this today you always do what we do I
had some your sister had some have some
beer I said no I don't feel right about
that y'all go ahead y'all go ahead and
then my brother started staring at me he
said what is what's wrong with you have
some beer then he looked at me real hard
he said oh I hope you're not still hung
up on that conversation mama had with
you
I said well what are you talking about
he says oh mama tells all the grandkids
that they're special i I was devastated
and I'm going to admit something to you
I'm going to tell you something I
probably shouldn't I know this might be
broadcast broadly but I'm I'm 52 years
old and I'm going to admit to you that
I've never had a drop of alcohol I don't
I don't say that because I think that's
virtuous I say that because there is
power in identity and talk about body
language today but look at that body
language that's strength there's power
in identity
so he's reinforcing his Twitter headline
his key theme with body language as well
and he's tying stories into it see with
communication folks I don't just make
this stuff up I'm trying to learn from
the best and if someone can successfully
argue a case in front of the Supreme
Court and when I asked them what's your
secret he goes I don't know I tell
stories what else am I supposed to
expect stories storytelling great
communicators tell stories just like
Marissa Mayer you can use stories in a
presentation or you can tell personal
stories stories are what are called
emotionally charged events when the
brain detects an emotionally charged
event it releases dopamine into the
system which acts as a mental post a
note saying remember this stories
connect with people what stories can I
tell and the only other technique that I
want to leave with you today this is
very important for all of you who give
presentations how many of you give like
PowerPoint presentations day to day or
frequently okay so most of you right
when you tell those stories make sure
that you're thinking visually because
that's the one thing that's going to
ruin the impact of those stories is
putting up a slide like this okay
that'll be it that's the end of your
story that's a real PowerPoint slide by
the way so you
they mentioned I wrote this book
presentation secrets of Steve Jobs this
came out several years ago I
talk a lot about the visual display of
information Steve Jobs didn't create it
but he happened to use it very very well
and a lot of I've been really gratified
because ever since then a lot of
business people I some very well-known
that have touched your life every day
and that you that you know very well
have called me or they send me emails
where they send me their slides ahead of
time and they're showing me how they're
incorporating visual design so whether
you read my stuff or Nancy Duarte spoke
here Garr Reynolds there's so many
different resources out there but the
point is start learning how to think
visually this is called picture
superiority picture superiority simply
means that when I deliver information
verbally you remember about ten percent
of it if I can add a picture though
retention goes up to sixty five percent
the average PowerPoint slide is 40 words
that doesn't surprise me
that doesn't when I first heard I
thought that's that's too much actually
no it's not it's very close to reality
great communicators it's hard to find 40
words in like 10 slides of their
presentations when Tim Cook at Apple has
a number when he wants to just introduce
a big statistic or a number that's all
you got to have on the slide is the
number five million if he wants to talk
about a product it's the product you
don't need to clutter slides with
bullets and text and bullets and text
especially when you tell stories let me
give you one example that I actually
delivered here a couple of years ago
remember I told you about the MacBook
Air the world's thinnest notebook well
if I'm going to tell you it's the
world's thinnest notebook boy that's
clear why would I clutter a slide and
make it look as ugly as this this is
what I think most people would have done
when they introduced a new product like
the MacBook Air let me put all the specs
on one slide and by the way I heard Carm
I mentioned something about visual
design so why don't I add some clipart
clipart of a battery up there and there
you have it that's a pretty ugly slide
Steve Jobs and Apple they thought about
it they thought creatively
well if it's as if it's that thin it
kind of fits inside one of those
envelopes that you see around the office
well why don't we just show that Oh
isn't that so much more powerful than
this that's memorable that's emotional
it makes a connection with you but that
takes work thinking visually takes work
and it also takes collaboration as well
so but that's ok collaborate with people
who might be better at something that
you are there are many people who are
better designers than I am so I
collaborate with them I'm very good at
telling them the story they collaborate
we came up with some pretty interesting
slides or images for certain events so
but think visually and finally I hate to
be the bearer of bad news but most
people don't care about your idea or
your product they care about themselves
I don't think most of you would disagree
with that they care about themselves
their hopes their dreams their goals
their ambitions if you can sell dreams
and not products that's how you'll win
them over if you can convince people
persuade them that by joining you on
your journey and your vision that
they're going to be taken to another
place that's how you're going to win
people over and today especially there's
a real lack of inspirational leadership
people crave inspiration they're hungry
for it they are looking for someone to
believe in make them believe in you
make sure you articulate and communicate
your message and your idea in a way that
truly inspires me that lifts my spirits
that takes me to another place that
makes me feel better about my place in
the world once you do that you'll win me
over and you'll have achieved a
significant step toward reaching your
dreams as well ok thank you very much
for inviting me for your for your lunch
break appreciate it thanks everyone
I do have a few minutes for questions if
anyone has anything specific yes sir
that's targeting business-to-consumer
interactions and I'm curious to know how
effective is what you're saying in a
business-to-business interaction where
you're dealing with potentially more
self-control sure the the question was a
lot of what I'm talking about was
applied to business to consumer
interactions all of these techniques
apply to the most complex idea in fact
the more complex your idea the harder it
is for people to grasp the more you need
to understand the really this is just
the theory of communication last year
and I'll be very careful with what I say
but last year I actually worked with
some nuclear scientists at a very large
nuclear lab in a desert somewhere and
true story nothing nothing that you do
in your career will be as complicated as
developing nuclear weapons it is really
complicated stuff but guess what they
loved all this they loved it there was a
lot of pushback it was one of the
roughest half-day workshops that I ever
had to give all of these scientists were
just pushing back and pushing back on
everything I was saying they wouldn't
even let me get one word out before they
started disagreeing with everything it
was - it was tough there was a really
tough workshop I mean I was just you
know drenched by the end I was exhausted
by the end of it two weeks later
scientists are calling me back and
sending me emails saying wow that word
we used it for a pitch in front of
Congress we've used it internally it
works it works because when you're
talking to people who don't understand
your story as well as you do and most
people don't you need to go through the
process how do I connect with them how
do I make this story which could be
incredibly complex how do I make it
understandable memoral
so that if they have to take it up to a
stakeholder they can do that and how do
I connect with them emotionally so by
the end of that presentation they like
me they want to work with me they don't
even know why they're not even sure why
they're connected with you emotionally
they just know that they like you and
these are some of the things that we do
yes sir
let us see an example of how you go into
a deep dive a deep dive from the message
mount it seems like right yet how do you
how do you extract it three main things
you can do that what I showed you was
the outline of the message map so you've
got your Twitter friendly headline and
you've got your rule of three I could
send you this too what we've done is we
actually create a message map where it's
still on one page but underneath each
one of these boxes you have rhetorical
devices that make your message even
stronger a story an example a statistic
so we're still breaking things up into
three this is this can be the foundation
of a 30 minute pitch a 30 minute
presentation it can be the foundation
for a 30 second elevator pitch that's
the beauty of it so the deep dive you
actually have underneath each category
so under fresh and organic I can have a
whole list of examples or statistics
that I can offer if the person wants to
know more about this but if that's all
they want to know then I can stick then
I can stay up here at that level so yeah
they're you absolutely do need to flesh
this out and I guess I should have been
specific when we do a four-hour workshop
on message Maps it's not just this it's
filling out the rest of the story as
well
you